estoy pensando en comprar un restaurante
así que voy y le pregunto al dueño
actual cuál es la distribución del
número de clientes que obtienes cada día
y me dice eso ya lo he calculado
mostrándome esta distribución
básicamente lo que se tiene es 10% de
clientes el lunes 10% martes 15%
miércoles y así sucesivamente cierran
los domingos así que esto es 100 por
ciento de los clientes de una semana si
los sumas de edad 100% yo obviamente
dure un poco así es que decido ver que
también que también se ajusta esta
distribución a datos realmente
observados decido observar el número de
clientes que asisten en la semana y esto
es lo que obtengo de datos observados
así que para resolver si quiero aceptar
o rechazar la hipótesis que él está
planteando aquí voy a hacer una pequeña
prueba de hipótesis establezco entonces
una hipótesis nula que la distribución
del dueño la distribución del dueño
esta que tenemos aquí la distribución
del dueño es correcta y la hipótesis
alternativa que la distribución del
dueño no es correcta que estos datos que
tenemos aquí no son los adecuados no
debe confiar en ellos y por lo tanto voy
a tener que rechazar la distribución del
dueño y quiero hacer esto con un nivel
de significancia del 5% un nivel de
significancia del 5% otra manera de
pensar en esto es que voy a calcular un
estadístico basado en los datos que
tenemos aquí va a ser un estadístico y
cuadrada o más bien el estadístico que
va a calcular va a seguir
aproximadamente una distribución de gi
cuadrada y dado que sigue una
distribución de g cuadrada con cierto
número de grados de libertad y eso lo
vamos a calcular y lo que quiero ver es
si la probabilidad de obtener un
resultado como éste o un resultado más
extremo que éste tiene una probabilidad
menor al 5% es decir si la probabilidad
tener un resultado como éste o más
extremo que éste es menor al 5% voy a
tener que rechazar la hipótesis
o lo que es lo mismo rechazar la
distribución del dueño si por el
contrario no ocurre eso si yo digo hay
la probabilidad de obtener un resultado
como esto o un resultado que sea más
extremo que esto sea un valor mayor al
nivel de significancia que establecimos
no la voy a rechazar no tengo razón para
asumir que me está engañando hagamos eso
para calcular el estadístico he cuadrada
vamos a suponer que la distribución del
dueño es la correcta
dueño es correcta así que asumiendo que
la distribución del dueño era correcta
cuáles serían los valores observados
esperados aquí tenemos los valores
esperados en porcentaje cuáles serían
los valores que esperaríamos observar
déjame escribirlo aquí esperados
agregamos el renglón de esperados así
que esperamos que el 10% en total de los
clientes venían el lunes 10% en total de
los clientes venían el martes 15 por
ciento el miércoles para calcular cuáles
son de hecho esos números necesitamos
calcular cuál es el total del número de
clientes
sumemos entonces estos números saquemos
la calculadora tenemos que son 30
+ 14 + 34 más 45 + 57 + 20 es lo cual
nos da un total de 200 clientes que
viene a una restaurante en esa semana
déjame escribir este valor tenemos un
total voy a ponerlo en esta columna
total ignore este valor de aquí total de
200 clientes entonces cuál es el valor
esperado para el lunes el lunes tenemos
un 10% de 200 esperamos 20 clientes
martes 10% de 200 también esperamos 20
clientes miércoles 15% de 200
esperamos 30 clientes jueves 20% de 200
son 40 clientes los que esperamos
viernes 30% de 200 esperamos 60 clientes
finalmente sábado 15% de 200 esperamos
30 clientes así si esta distribución es
correcta estos son los números que
esperaríamos ahora para calcular el
estadístico y cuadrada esencialmente lo
que hace es dejar
mostrarte lo por acá voy a usar una
equis mayúscula al cuadrado algunas
gentes usan la letra g la letra griega
he al cuadro para usar la x mayúscula al
cuadrado déjame escribirlo así esto va a
ser estadístico de estadístico de y
cuadrada estadístico eje cuadrada y lo
voy a escribir con la x en vez de la he
porque va a ser una aproximación a la
distribución de g cuadrada no podemos
asumir que es exacta estamos más bien
tratando con una aproximación a la
distribución y es un cálculo inmediato
para cada uno de los días tomamos el
valor observado menos el esperado
aquí tenemos entonces para el lunes que
sería 30 menos 20 y estoy usando para
esto el código los colores tenemos esta
diferencia elevada al cuadrado entre el
valor esperado básicamente lo que
tenemos es el cuadrado ya lo que sería
como el error entre el observado y lo
esperado la diferencia del valor
observado y el valor esperado y esto
normalizado aquí por el valor esperado y
queremos tomar la suma de todos estos lo
voy a hacer en amarillo
así más 14 menos 20 14 menos 20 al
cuadrado sobre el valor esperado que es
20 más 34 menos 30 al cuadrado 34 menos
30 al cuadrado sobre 30 más lo voy a
poner acá abajo más 45 menos 40 al
cuadrado sobre 40 más 57 menos 60 al
cuadrado 57 menos 60 al cuadrado sobre
60 y finalmente más 20 más 20 menos 30
al cuadrado sobre 30 simplemente tome el
cuadrado del observado menos el esperado
lo dirigente el valor esperado tome la
suma de estos valores y eso nos dio el
estadístico y cuadrada calculemos
entonces cuánto nos va a dar este valor
esto va a ser igual a lo va a hacer por
acá abajo para que no me quede sin
espacio luego hacen otro color lo hacen
naranja esto va a ser igual a 30 menos
20 al cuadrado
ser 10 al cuadrado que es 100 dividido
entre 20 esto es igual a 5 más quizás no
puedo hacer todos tus valores
mentalmente entonces dejar ponerlo de
esta manera sería 100 entre 10 al quad 2
100 entre 20 más
aquí tenemos 14 menos 20 menos 6 al
cuadrado aquí tendríamos 36 sobre 20 más
34 menos 34 al cuadrado 16 sobre 30 más
45 menos 45 al cuadrado 25 entre 40 más
57 menos 60 es igual a menos 3 al
cuadrado es 9 entre 60 más 20 menos 30
es menos 10 al cuadrado es 100 más 100
sobre 30 y esto es igual a
de sacar la calculadora nuevamente que
tenemos aquí tenemos qué
100 entre 20 más 36 entre 20 más 16
entre 30 más 25 entre 40 más 9 entre 60
más 100 entre 30 y esto es igual a 11.44
esto es igual a 11.44 déjame apuntarlo
por acá
11.44 nuestro estadístico de cuadra de
11.44 que aquí lo pongo con x mayúscula
al cuadrado en algunas ocasiones se pone
la letra griega y cuadrada pero aquí
tenemos una distribución aproximada así
cuadrada en fin habiendo dicho esto
vamos a calcular si suponemos que hay
aproximadamente una distribución y
cuadrada cuál es la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado tanto o más extremo
que este otra manera de decirlo es
existe un valor más extremo que el valor
crítico de ji cuadrada para el cual hay
una probabilidad del 5% de obtenerse
hagamos eso
busquemos nuestro valor crítico de ji
cuadrada y si este valor es más extremo
que s rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
encontremos entonces el valor crítico de
ji cuadrada
tenemos una alfa del 5% y una de las
cosas que tenemos que calcular también
es el número grados de libertad aquí
obtuvimos la suma para uno dos tres
cuatro cinco o seis valores por lo que
es tentador decir que el número de
libertad en 6
darse cuenta que si tenemos toda esta
información por aquí puedes calcular
esta última pieza de información por lo
cual tenemos 5 grados de libertad cuando
tienes n valores de datos como aquí que
estás comparando observado contra
esperado tus grados de libertad van a
ser n menos 1 pues puedes calcular el
enésimo dato basado en la información
que se tiene y en el menos un datos
así es que nuestro caso el 9 grados de
libertad son 5 n 1 entonces nuestro
nivel de significancia es 5 % nuestros
grados de libertad
grados de libertad también son igual a 5
y lo ubicamos en la tabla de
distribución de he cuadrada aquí tenemos
5 grados de libertad tenemos por acá el
nivel de significancia de punto 0 55 % y
el valor crítico resulta entonces
11.07 veamos esta gráfica por acá aquí
tenemos la instrucción y cuadrada con 5
grados de libertad
aquí tenemos en color magenta dicha
distribución tenemos un nivel de punto 0
5 que es 11.07 si seguimos aquí la línea
magenta si la continuamos por acá para
ubicar el valor deseado el valor crítico
aquí tenemos 8 10 está más o menos por
aquí aquí tenemos 12 y 11 puntos 0 7
estaría aproximadamente por aquí y lo
que esto dice entonces es que la
probabilidad de obtener un valor al
menos tan extremo como 11.07 este 5% 5%
comparemos con nuestro resultado tenemos
que no es
valor crítico de sí cuadrada el valor
crítico de ji cuadrado es igual a déjame
checar en la tabla de nuevo es 11.07
entonces tenemos un valor crítico de ji
cuadrada de 11.07 y el resultado que
obtuvimos de nuestro estadístico de
11.44 es aún menos probable que eso la
probabilidad es menor que el nivel de
significancia por lo cual vamos a
rechazar deja de ponerlo de esta manera
el valor de 11.44 11.44 11.44 es más
extremo que el valor crítico de 11.07
por lo cual es muy improbable que esta
distribución sea verdadera tenemos que
rechazar lo que él nos está diciendo
tenemos que rechazar esta distribución
pues hemos encontrado que no hay un buen
ajuste basado en este nivel de
significancia